and the housing market crunch continues
to shatter records las vegas realtors
say tight supply and high prices do
continue in january the median cost of a
single family home 435 000
that is up 90 000 from a year ago the
median price of condos in town homes
243k that is up 50 grand in a year
prices for town homes homes and condos
all breaking december record highs
and home prices not the only concern
yeah rising interest rates are too and a
lot of people are now getting more
desperate to try and close on a house
before those interest rates go up joe
moeller spoke to a lender about what
they're expecting moving forward
we've watched home prices go up and up
and now with mortgage rates still on the
rise more people are now rushing to buy
a home the pressure is on to find a
house daphne garcia quintero is eager to
get her first home hopefully we can find
something in the next couple months the
search over the past year has not been
easy with such low inventory she says so
many cash offers were beating her out
but now there is another worry with the
median of like the houses selling going
up but also like the interest rate going
up you're looking at so much more that
you're paying monthly so now is it
feasible the average price of a home now
435 thousand dollars a record for las
vegas but that price could cost you more
in a few months with changing rates they
always ask when's the best time to buy
our answers always yesterday a recent
rate hike in december now means buyers
will pay more a month now than they
would for that same home a few months
ago residential bancorp lender daniel
herrera says rates are expected to go up
again this spring about quarter percent
out of time is generally what we see
what used to be the common three percent
rate now we're looking at the common
four percent rate he expects a few more
increases in 2022. we figure the fed's
going to meet again at the end of march
that's when you see the the market all
over the place not just the real estate
market but the entire market actually
shifts and waiting could cause buyers
more down the road definitely puts fire
under us to definitely find something
within
the next couple of months joe muller
live local now